Hello, welcome to class. Again, welcome. My name is David Brown and this is going to be an original combo reading writing and grammar class. I'm glad that you're all here. Have a seat everybody. Welcome.
Hey, Hector. How are you?
Just fine. How are you?
I'm doing great. Thank you.
Welcome. Welcome.
Thank you.
I see that you selected a class about arguments. Would you like to learn how to be more persuasive in today's class?
I would like to. I would love to actually because that's a very important thing to do when you speak another language.
Yeah, the basic question of this is what do we want and how do we get that? And communication is the means in which we acquire the things that we want.
So learning to be persuasive is just really an amazing soft skills to learn.
And there are procedures that we can follow in order to persuade effectively. So in today's lesson, we'll talk about persuading effectively and about some grammar reading and writing task that can help us to persuade formally.
We have this concept of cohesion and cohesion is when something is whole.
In order to make a good argument, we need to have all the parts of the argument.
And we also need the argument to be smooth. It has to flow. So we have cohesion and those two concepts that we'll talk about a little bit today.
So let's explore how we can achieve this.
So I have an image on the screen here. It says from jumbled ideas to a clear persuasive point.
We see this guy with a messy room.
He's torn over curtain there.
And it makes it look clean there.
It actually looks like mine.
All right, all right.
We have our arguments are like this, right?
Our arguments can be messy or they can be organized.
And if our arguments are presented in an organized way, then we're more likely to convince people that something is true.
We want to do this genuinely. How can we genuinely organize our ideas to make a persuasive point?
Let's see if you can remember something about arguments or tell me what you think you know about persuasion.
What are two parts of an argument that you remember?
Remember any specific parts?
Actually, I can't remember it.
You know, like being so organized.
And let me see the other one.
You said, organized.
And messy.
Okay.
And the opposite will be organized, right?
So being organized versus his versus messy.
How about the structure of an argument?
How do you argue effectively?
What is something that you need to do in order to make a good argument?
Well, actually, I need to, I need to make it so comprehensive.
Right? For the person that is.
Listen to one argument. Right?
And it has to be easy.
To understand.
And easy to understand too.
Agreed.
So if we improve some of these aspects of grammar, like cohesion and flow, we can make it easier to understand.
We can make it organized and not messy.
And we can make it whole. We can make it comprehensive.
So these are our learning objectives for today's class.
Can you read this first objective for us?
Yeah, learning objectives for today.
Analyze a model argument for structure and flow.
You want me to read all of them?
Okay.
Utilize a graphic organizer to the construct arguments.
Understand how grammatical choices impact clearly.
And cohesion.
Practice using transitional device says effectively.
And identify and correct common errors affecting argument clearly.
Alright, let's practice two of these words here.
This one is pronounced repeat after me clarity, clarity.
Oh, clarity.
Okay.
And this one is with a Jen sound, like a Z.
ZJ kind of sound cohesion.
Cohesion and clarity.
Okay.
Yeah, I didn't notice it was.
The word as with clear.
I confuse it actually.
Yeah, it's related to the word clear.
So clear.
Yeah, it's related.
The same thing.
Right.
That's what I think.
Uh huh.
So you have clarity, which is the noun and something is clear.
It's the adjective.
Yeah.
Alright.
So what we can start off with first is the anatomy of an argument.
The different parts of an argument.
And this is something that we can learn.
And remember from the days in school, when we would write essays and things like that.
How do you structure an essay?
What comes first, next, and then last, when you write?
Let's read this part here.
Can you read this paragraph for me?
Sure.
A well crafted argument resembles a well engineered structure.
It requires robust components and seamless connections.
Cohesion ensures ideas interlinked logically.
While fluency allows the reader to navigate the argument smoothly.
Okay, excellent.
So I made this image here to demonstrate this idea geometrically.
So we have the idea that an argument is complete.
But an argument can be complete, but not flow well.
An argument can have all of the parts, but they're not put together.
So if we look at each stage of this, we see that it starts with a few elements that are not connected very well.
They're not connected via the reasoning that we need.
We see that it starts to form, but it doesn't have good flow.
And when the flow improves, we end with the perfect circle.
So this illustrates the idea of a cohesion, which is it being whole.
The hexagon in this picture has cohesion, but it doesn't have flow.
This circle, on the other hand, has cohesion and has flow.
So how can we do that?
How can we structure our paragraphs and our essays?
So that it is organized that it contains all of the parts that it needs.
And so that it transitions from one part to the next logically.
And if we do that right, if we do it effectively, then we have both of those elements and we strengthen our argument.
So we have these argumentative elements, the puzzle pieces, cohesion, the connective structure, and the fluency, the smooth flow between ideas.
All right. So we need to remember these core components of an argument.
Let's read these here. Can you read these for me?
Sure. Can I read it from the very beginning?
Like recall the core components of an argument, claim, actually, background, ceases,
topic sentences, evidence, examples, potential, rebuttal,
and conclusion, a solid grasp of this element is foundational.
Very good.
So we have the claim. Another word for claim is a thesis.
We have the background, which is the context of what we're talking about.
If we start talking and we start arguing, but nobody knows what we're talking about with the background of it, then it's not clear.
So we start with a claim.
We can give us some background information about that.
And then we have our thesis statement.
This is a thesis statement that is basically the main argument of the entire thing we're trying to convince the other person to believe.
So to persuade is to convince someone else to believe something.